Today I'll talk about
advancing robot intelligence
with reinforcement learning.
And before I zoom into robotics
or reinforcement learning,
I'll take a step back.
And I'll first contrast
reinforcement learning
with imitation learning.
So one thing to note
here is that I'm
going to compare
imitation learning that
actually works with
reinforcement learning that
actually works.
That doesn't mean that they
don't exist reinforcement
learning algorithms which don't
follow this characteristics,
but these are the
characteristics
of the ones that have
been the most successful
at actually solving
extremely hard problems.
So for imitation
learning, it is widely
used for pre-training
vision language models.
It's also used for video
generation image segmentation.
So the first two are
probably more popular.
For image segmentation,
you get an image.
And it will segment out
different parts of the image.
The best models that
we have today for these
are trained using some
form of imitation learning.
And reinforcement
learning, the places
where it has delivered the best
results, one is game playing.
So for example, the game of
Go, also games in simulation.
It has also delivered
results in reasoning
for large language models,
which is significantly
beyond what the imitation
learning pre-training could
achieve.
And the last one is
robotics, which I will
get into the rest of the talk.
So the key characteristics that
successful imitation learning
has used is that it
relies on off-policy data.
So this data is collected
or generated by humans
or collected in
sources which have
nothing to do with the final
policy that you're improving.
In contrast, the reinforcement
learning that has succeeded
is typically on policy.
So the policy that
you want to improve
is the one you roll
out to generate
the distribution of the data
set and then you somehow
use to improve your policy.
In imitation learning, you take
your data set, you clean it up,
you get the good
data set, and then
you use that to
train your model.
But in reinforcement
learning, every data point
that is generated during the
policy rollout is fair game.
So you can use all of that to
improve and update your policy.
And that actually is one of the
things that makes reinforcement
learning quite powerful.
So you learn from not
just the positive but also
the negative data, which gives
you very precise behaviors
that you want.
And typically,
imitation learning
has given us generalists.
It gives you this
one single model
that can do a bunch of things.
Reinforcement learning
either gives specialists
or it helps you specialize
pre-trained general models.
So this contrast
is just to give you
a sense of the difference
between the two.
That is not to say that one is
strictly better than the other.
So even for the game
of Go, there were--
we use imitation
learning for warm
starting the reinforcement
learning self-play or search.
And same with language models.
So you use imitation
learning to warm-start
your whole model and then
you can get reasoning
or whatever it is that
you want to improve
the performance on top of that.
So now, let's zoom into
reinforcement learning.
And the first question is,
what has it actually achieved?
Qualitatively, what
behaviors has it achieved,
which is the only way
to do those things?
So for AlphaGo, it learned to--
AlphaGo, it's a game of Go.
And we have a system
called AlphaGo
which can defeat the best
Go player in the world.
And what it has learned
to do is to exceed
what humans can do by figuring
out innovative or new behaviors
that humans have
not seen before.
Similarly, for
reasoning and LLMs,
it can go significantly
beyond what
you can achieve with
just imitation learning,
and it can give you results just
significantly better than what
you would get otherwise.
The key thing that
it shows here is
very coherent and
precise reasoning
over very long horizon tasks.
So this is another
characteristic
that we know that reinforcement
learning can give us.
And the last thing is
dexterity in robotics,
which I'll get to soon.
So if you look at
all three of these,
there's one question that, what
is common between all three
of these which lets us achieve
the scale of results we
do with reinforcement learning?
So I would like to point
out two things which
let us on-policy reinforcement
learning shine in all three
of these domains.
The first is
well-specified rewards.
So for AlphaGo, the reward
was a very sparse one.
It was very clear.
If you won the
game of Go, you can
look at the state of the
world, and you can define
if you won the game or not.
Similarly for
reasoning and LLMs,
if we look at this
DeepSeek carbon paper,
they say that we use
a rule-based reward
function, which is
very clear to evaluate.
And now, since it is
rule-based, you can automate it.
And you can get it very
cleanly and clearly at scale.
And the second
critical component
is, can we run these
policies at scale?
So with AlphaGo, since we
know the rules of the games,
we can put that
game in simulation.
And now it scales
beautifully with compute.
So we can just
throw compute at it.
You can evaluate the policies.
And we can convert
that compute to data,
which we will then
use reinforcement
learning to improve the model.
Similarly for reasoning in
LLMs, you can just roll them out
in a cluster and
you can evaluate
them using some form of an
automatic reward function,
making this an extremely
scalable way of collecting data
for reinforcement learning,
and also evaluating it,
and then improving it.
So I would argue that
these two things are--
all of these results happened
seven to eight years--
spaced out by seven
to eight years.
And all of these
successes still have
these very two key ingredients
which lets it succeed.
So now, I'll get into--
zoom into robotics with a focus
on what these ingredients are.
So if you zoom into robotics,
the results I'll present
are from three, four years ago.
And the question is what
let us succeed in robotics
with the same algorithm?
So the closest approximation
to getting these ingredients
is to use simulation.
So if we use simulation,
we can programmatically
calculate rewards because we
have full state of the world.
And we can also evaluate
policies in scale
because we have converted
a physical problem
to a digital problem, which now
just will scale with compute.
So this gets us to solving
robotics and simulation.
But that is not the
same as solving robotics
in the real world.
So how do we get robotics
in the real world?
By just tackling the
sim to real challenge.
So how do we train
policies and simulation?
And then how do we move
them to the real world?
And that will be the
focus of this talk.
Before I get into how we solve
these sim to real problem,
let me convince you first
that this actually works.
So I'll start with the
results, real-world results
of robots in the wild.
So this is in Berkeley.
And the robot is--
everything is
real-time on board.
The robot is blind, and it's
trying to get over these rocks
and the feet get stuck.
It keeps trying and
then figures out
that there's something and
then continues to walk.
Here it has these staircases
that it cannot see.
So it's a bit fumbly
in these staircases,
but it can still get
them and doesn't fall.
He also tried on
this grass patch.
Even if you had vision
in this scenario,
you would not see the
ground underneath.
So you need a certain
level of robustness
just to get through
some of these.
And here the ground is
sloping to the left.
I think there's a big
ditch on the left.
It still manages to not
just drift all the way
and counter that.
This is a construction
site in front of my house
when I was in Berkeley.
And we were able to repeat this.
And it can reliably get down
this very unstable ground.
And here it's slightly muddy,
so the feet get stuck once
in a while, but it
knows how to correct
for it by applying more
force and then just
like getting out of it.
And this is just
walking on sand.
So the important point here
is that all of these results
are from the exact same policy.
So the exact same weights
deployed zero shot
in the real world without any
tuning or specific improvement
related to any of
these terrains.
And the question is,
how do we get it?
So that is the
focus of this work.
This was published
in RSS in 2021.
So let's start by learning
to walk in simulation.
So the idea is simple.
Let's just pretend that this
simulation is the real world
and everything we can
access is fair game.
So we want to train
a neural network.
That's your base policy.
It will take an
action in simulation.
Simulation will simulate
one tick of the real world,
and then it will
give you the updated
state of the simulation,
which the policy can consume,
and then it can walk.
So this would be a
very narrow policy
that can walk in one scenario.
And maybe we can deploy
it in the real world
by tuning some parameters
of the physics.
But this is not good
enough because we actually
don't want a single policy.
We want a generalist
policy that can
walk in all of these scenarios.
So we will randomize all of
these parameters in simulation.
And the important part is we
will let the policy have access
to all of these parameters.
So now when we
train this policy,
it can walk, not just
for any specific value
of mass or friction.
It would have seen
a huge range of it,
and it will know how
to walk accordingly.
So it's not oblivious or
blind to the environment.
It's actually aware of
what it's dealing with.
And for the purposes
of this talk,
we'll call this compressed
vector extrinsics.
And then the reward
function we use
is to track a certain
target velocity, and then
a certain other set
of reward functions
which minimize work
and ground impact.
We'll train this whole
system end-to-end with PPO.
Takes about a billion samples
to train it in this simulation.
This is [? resin. ?]
And once we have this,
now we can think about
how to deploy it.
But before that, let's maybe
zoom in into the reward function
that we have.
So we have 10 different
reward functions.
This is not very
elegant, but we tried
to be as principled as we can.
So the forward and the
latter-- so the first reward
function is just
specify the task.
So what is the task that
we're trying to solve?
And then there are a
bunch of reward functions
which minimize energetics.
And then the last one is
stability and minimizing
hardware damage, because
in simulation there's
no concept of hardware damage.
So we need to inject
all of those biases
so that it can learn
something which can actually
transfer to the real world.
So coming back to how
can we deploy it--
well, this vector is
unknown in the real world.
And even if I estimated
that in my living room,
it would still not be
enough, because the moment
I get to something which
is not my living room,
let's say sand or mulch or any
of those, it would fail to work,
and I have to retune it again.
So the key idea that
we will use here
is we will estimate
this online in fractions
of a second at runtime.
And the reason why
we can estimate it
at all in the
first place is by--
the way we will
estimate-- the signal that
will be used to estimate it
is the observation history,
so the series of commands
that are executed
and the commands that
were actually issued.
We will use that as our
input into the system
to estimate this online.
And the reason this signal has
the right thing that we care
about is-- let's say that
you give a command to walk,
and then one of your
leg slips more than
what you expected it to.
You're at the discrepancy
between your signal
and what you actually
[? commanded ?] will tell you
that you actually slipped.
This was not intentional.
You slipped forward.
So the idea is to use the
history of this signal
to estimate what
these extrinsics are.
And then this discrepancy
between the actual movement
and the measured
movement is what
will let us estimate
this online at runtime
in fractions of a second.
So the next question
is, how do we
train this model so that we can
deploy it in the real world?
And the idea is simple.
We'll just go back
to simulation.
And in simulation, we
have the ground truth.
And we also have the history.
So we will use dagger in which
you roll out the student policy
to generate the
data distribution,
and then you use the teacher
to supervise every single point
of the student policy.
You will use that to train the
student model, which is now
using this history
of observations
to continuously estimate
what this extrinsic z is,
which will then be fed into the
base policy which is trained
with reinforcement learning.
And we copied over the weights.
And then we can now
deploy this online.
So one thing to note
here is, the base policy
runs at 100 Hertz.
And the adaptation
module, which is
the one that estimates
this extrinsics,
that only runs at 10 Hertz.
And this is not by choice.
It's because of whatever
compute was available on board.
And we see that the
performance doesn't drop.
So this was not accounted
for during training.
So in training we
train everything
at 100 Hertz in lockstep.
And once we deploy it,
we see that this can only
run at 10 Hertz, and
this runs at 100 Hertz.
And that is good enough to
get the results that we want.
So let's start with
evaluating it indoors.
This is my living room, and
I'll pour some oil in it.
This is a plastic tarp.
I think that is olive oil.
This is a while ago.
So this a plastic tarp
on which I evaluated.
And then the robot's feet also
have plastic covered on top
of it, partially to
make it challenging,
but also to protect
the feet of the robot.
And it slips a bit here, but
it continues to march forward
without an issue.
You can slow it down and see.
This is where it
starts slipping,
and it seems to maintain
balance and not flip over.
Similarly, here I'm throwing
a 5 Kg payload on the robot,
and it seems to be doing fine.
Just to be clear,
this robot is 12 Kgs.
5 Kgs is roughly half
the weight of the robot.
I can make this a bit slower.
And you see what
actually goes down
if you focus on the green dots.
In a few steps, it
tries to go back up
and recover the regular motion
style that it is working with.
Similarly, here, it's like the
foothold is not even stable.
So this plank just
moves with the foot.
So there's no clear estimate
of the ground that you can get.
And it's still walking.
All of these results
are blind by the way.
There's no vision.
All of these just use
proprioception history.
And I evaluated it on a bunch of
places, including my mattress,
on foam, taking a step down,
step up, and all of these.
And it was relatively robust
in all of these scenarios.
So let's see what happens if
we switch up this adaptation
module.
So what this means is we
estimate the extrinsics
at the first time step.
And then we freeze that update.
And then we don't
update the extrinsics
for the rest of the run.
And it looks like it is--
8 Kg.
This is like a 12 Kg robot,
and 8 Kg is very high.
And you can see the robot
is struggling a bit.
So the rated payload
for this robot
when I bought it was
around 3 kilograms.
Maxing this out heats
the motors much faster,
but it can still manage to walk.
If you switch off this
adaptation module--
So the weight actually
tilts the bot forward
and it doesn't know to correct
for it by applying more force
or torque in the front legs or
get back to a higher clearance
and just ends up
tilting forward when
it doesn't have enough torque
to clear for the next step.
Same thing with the foam.
Even if it is getting stuck,
it seems to manage that fine.
But here, it doesn't know
to again apply more force
to get higher
clearance to continue
walking because
it hasn't detected
that event or that change.
So let's zoom into what is this
adaptation module doing exactly.
So this is the plastic surface
that I showed you before.
It's flipped.
And there are three
plots that I have here.
So the top plot is what
is called a gait plot.
So these are the four
feet of the robot.
And anytime a line
is solid, it means
that the feet is in contact.
There are feet sensors in the
hardware which let us plot this.
The second plot is
the amount of torque
being requested in the front
right knee of the robot.
And Z1 and Z5 are
two values that we
have taken from the
adaptation module,
and we've just plotted them.
I chose these two because
they show the most variation
in the course of this run.
So if you see that
the moment it slips,
there's some
shuffling in the gait.
We also see a variation
in the torque profile.
And we see that the
adaptation module
changes its value to capture
that something has happened.
Since these are
learned extrinsics,
we cannot interpret
them very easily,
but we see that some
change has happened.
And after that, it seems to
have recovered to the same gait
pattern and a similar
torque profile
as before once the event is
detected in the bottom graph.
Similarly, for this
example, there's a--
the 5 Kg payload,
which is dropped,
which means that at
the time of impact,
the force is probably even more.
And we can do the same test.
And we see that there's, again,
the shuffling of this gait.
And the torque is very high
at the moment when this drops,
but it comes back
to a regular gait.
But the torque that it
saturates to after it tries to--
after it is done with
adapting to this event,
the torque it saturates
to is higher than
before because it
needs more torque
to balance the way
that it is carrying.
So let's get into some
quantitative comparison.
The first baseline is a very
simple change over this.
It's just train a policy
without the knowledge
of changing environments.
You just trained
a policy which is
blind and robust to every
single thing it can potentially
encounter.
This is a very common
technique which is used,
which is just
domain randomization
without necessarily caring about
if you are giving this input
to the policy or not.
This is one of the baselines.
In the row above expert
is the RMA baseline.
That's the method
that I just presented.
Stands for Rapid
Motor Adaptation.
And if you compare
that with robust,
we see that it is
a bit conservative,
but it also has a
weaker success rate.
And the amount of torque
it's exerting is also higher.
The amount of jerk
that it experiences
is higher because it has no idea
of the environment around it.
It is just trying to be
as aggressive as possible
to make sure that
it does not fall.
The second baseline we have
is for system identification.
The goal for system
identification
is to estimate things
like friction and mass
and all of these
other parameters
explicitly, and then
use them downstream.
So in this instantiation of
system identification, what
we try to do is instead
of trying to predict
the extrinsics, which
is a compressed version
of these environment
parameters, we directly
go for these SysID parameters.
So we directly try to
predict friction and all
of these other parameters.
So this is a hard
problem, to predict
exactly what the friction is,
because you might not even
detect the full
scope of the slip,
or you might not even know
exactly how much the mass is.
But it's also not
necessary to solve
for the final downstream
task of working robustly.
And we see the
gap in performance
if we try to explicitly
estimate these parameters.
And interestingly,
it's lower than
having a robust policy,
which is just agnostic to it
and just learns a gait, which is
robust to all of these changes
to begin with.
The third baseline
is one that tries
to fine-tune at inference time.
So you take a policy
from simulation.
And to bridge the
sim to real gap,
you roll it out
in the real world,
and then you improve the policy.
This is one way
of achieving that.
The RMA style is
closer to in-context
learning where you take
the history of everything,
and then the learning happens
in the feedforward pass itself.
So you see all of
these parameters.
And then you estimate how
the network should behave,
which lets it do it in
fractions of a second instead
of trying to estimate
that at inference time
by rolling out policies.
And then the last baseline
is one with adaptation.
So if you switch off adaptation,
the performance falls.
We did this quantitatively,
qualitatively.
And we have numbers in
the real world as well.
We see that the performance is
lower than just using [? arm. ?]
And there's a
small amount of gap
between what we
get from the expert
and from distilling it into an
RMA method which can actually
be deployed.
So everything that I've
shown up until now is blind.
And the next thing
that I'll do--
so if you want to
strive towards having
some form of a
general robot model,
it needs to have
perception or vision.
And I will try to add vision to
what I just showed for walking.
But we already saw all of
these results without vision.
So the first question is, do we
even need vision for walking?
Is it a good test?
Do we even need
vision for walking?
Can we not just do
without any vision
altogether, given the
results we have already seen?
And the answer is that the
two scenarios, in one case,
vision is critical.
If you are to cross these
gaps or stepping stones
or make a jump, you
need vision to estimate
how to make that jump.
And the second argument is more
of an efficiency and elegance
and longevity argument.
So if you have to
collide with a staircase
every single time that
you climb it, it's not--
it's a very inelegant
policy that will--
and the hardware will
probably not survive for long.
So for both of these reasons, if
you have a vision in the loop,
you can potentially
get to results
which are much better than what
we can achieve without vision.
And that will be the
focus of this work.
This was published
[? and coded ?] 2022.
So to repeat the
question, your question
is, has there been
follow-up work
done to use the rollouts
in the real world
to improve the policy?
So there are two parts
to this question.
The one part is the sheer power
of using a general learning
algorithm, which is--
if you use reinforcement
learning, in the limit,
you can learn whatever behavior
it is that you want to learn.
And then there is
this argument of,
if the policy makes a mistake
and figures out in a few tries
how to fix it, will it
remember it in the future?
So the first part, I
think, is an open problem,
and we still don't have a
method which can continuously
improve perpetually online.
The second part of your
question is a simpler problem,
which is correlate-- which is--
where the simpler answer might
be to just increase the context
that you give to the policy.
So if you figure out a way to
compress the context of one day
into the policy or two
days into the policy,
you can imagine the
in-context learning
to be sufficient to let it
remember how it fixed it
the last time and get it right
in one shot in the future.
So there are two ways
to get to what you said.
One of them is more powerful,
but also very slow to learn.
And the other thing lets
you learn much faster
in a much simpler way.
It's not obvious which
one is more complete.
I can see a system which has
infinite context, like what
humans have, and is capable
of maintaining a memory, which
lets us continuously improve
in the feedforward pass itself
without needing to take--
without having to take
reinforcement learning
gradients.
There's no reason
that cannot happen.
But then the burden
of that shifts
to how do you train this model.
So you need to do
something in simulation
to get that behavior out of it.
Yes, you can train directly
with phase 2 with more compute.
I was using a
CPU-based simulation.
[? With ?] a
GPU-based simulation
with more GPUs,
that is possible.
Most successful sim
to real policies
are actually the ones
which don't have a history.
They usually just use the
current state to deploy.
And my guess for
why that is the case
is because the moment you
have only the current state
that you're using to deploy, it
becomes a state-indexed policy
as opposed to a state
and time-indexed policy.
So if you were to
have a history,
you need to make sure that
the distribution you see
in your history and you
randomize it sufficiently enough
that when you go
into the real world,
there's no exploitation that
happened during training, which
is preventing it
from transferring
as well to the real world.
Sorry.
To repeat the question--
the question was,
can we just directly
train phase 2?
And the answer is yes,
you can with more compute.
But you need to be
careful with sim
to real because the more
information you give it
in sim, which is possible if
you have a very, very long
and dense history, it might
learn to exploit things off
either your
environment or physics
in simulation or your
reward structure.
And we do see this.
If you give a periodic--
if you give a periodic
push to the robot,
it is very common for
the robot to just learn
to be very robust when
it expects the push,
when it has a long
enough context,
or it has a notion of time.
But when you randomize
that as well,
then you can get around it.
So it is possible.
You just need to be more careful
with how you train your policy.
So the physical
parameters in this is--
there's a 2x compression here,
half of what the relative is.
The extrinsics are around eight.
I think the full physical
parameters are maybe 17 or 18.
In this version of vision, there
will be a much more aggressive
compression where it
goes from the full image
to a much smaller encoder.
The question is, in
the series of rewards
that we have, how do
we balance between all
of these different rewards?
There's no good way to do it.
That is the real answer.
I think it's a
very hard problem.
The practical way to do it is
to add one reward at a time,
and then try to
see what is lacking
in the current set of rewards.
Add a new reward, and
then tune only that reward
relative to every other reward.
So instead of this
exponential complexity,
you can reduce it somewhat
to just adding one at a time.
But this is probably not--
the coefficients we get are
probably not the most optimal
you can get.
So the question is, in
input to the policy,
we use the current state
and the previous action.
What if we don't use
the previous action?
So previous action has a very
important signal to give,
which is, what is the command
that I give in the last time
step?
This lets you be
smooth, consistent,
and it also lets you show some
amount of correction behavior.
So if this action
didn't work and you're
conditioned on that
action, you know
that the next action
that you have to predict
needs to be higher.
So the state is lossy.
If you remove the
previous action,
my guess is that the
performance will drop compared
to having the action as input.
The question is,
what happens if you
use two or three or more time
steps of the state history?
That's related to
the other question,
where what if we train the
full system end-to-end directly
[? face ?] to using
reinforcement learning?
You can do that.
You just need to be a
bit careful with sim
to real transfer, because now it
has more context and information
to potentially exploit the
simulation or your environment
or your reward structure in ways
which might not be desirable.
The question is, what--
to just quickly explain dagger.
It's a very standard algorithm,
where what we do here,
we apply that--
the way we apply it here is
to run the phase 2 policy.
So we initialize the adaptation
module, which is random weights.
We run the phase 2
policy, collect the data.
Initially, it's just
going to be bad data
because it hasn't learned
to do anything meaningful.
And then we'll use
the teacher encoder
to supervise at every time step.
What should the
prediction have been?
And then we will
just use supervised
learning to update
the adaptation module.
We will take it
back in simulation.
We will roll it again.
It will hopefully be better than
what it did before, but still
not optimal.
And then we will again supervise
it with the teacher module,
get the data set, run supervised
learning, and then repeat.
So switching to adding vision--
so the most common
approach to add vision
is to decouple it
entirely from control
and then build an explicit
map that you can then
feed into your controller
to use that to walk.
And the reason this--
there's a fundamental flaw
in this approach,
which is, first of all,
you're solving a very
hard problem, which
is building an explicit map.
So your map will
always be noisy.
So if you have non-rigid
objects or if you
have drift in estimate of
your pose or any of these,
it will end up converging
to very noisy maps.
So that is a phase where you
have already lost information,
and there is no way you can
recover that information.
And then you feed that
into the controller.
So since we are solving
a harder problem,
we are losing information
that we, in other scenarios,
would not have lost if we were
to directly use the perception
input in the policy.
So here's an example
of how people add noise
to the real terrain.
Maybe the edges were enough to
tell you how to take that step,
but the moment you
convert it to a metric map
and then try to give
that into the policy,
now you need to
train your policy
to be robust to all of these
different kinds of noises, which
is OK for simple scenarios,
but becomes very challenging
the moment you have--
you need to precisely
estimate where the gap is
and avoid stepping on that.
So what we do in this work
is we ask this question,
do we need terrain maps?
Do we need to
explicitly build them?
The answer, we
hypothesize that we don't.
And instead, we directly
couple vision and control
in the final system.
So here is what that system
looks like in deployment.
And I'll get to
how do we train it.
So in the top right is the depth
egocentric that the bot can see.
I've taped the cameras
and compute and everything
on the bot.
So everything is running
on board in real time.
And it's trying to--
so it's trying to cross
over these stepping stones.
This is my living
room, and these--
just got 20 stools and then
just got it to walk on it.
And it's like repeated runs
with different levels of gaps
and variations so
that you can test
that it's actually
using perception
to handle all of these.
And here it's some hiking path
where the stairs are uneven.
And the robot is
actually quite small.
So if you give it a
second here-- if you see,
the height of the step is
almost as high as the robot,
and it struggles a bit, but it
manages to climb it at the end.
Similarly, first, as we tested
it on uneven stairs uptown,
all of that across, and
it was relatively robust.
And if you see how much it
has to get down once it is up,
it is actually quite sharp
for a robot of this size.
And here the ground
is extremely slippery.
There's barely a stable foothold
for the bot, but it keeps trying
and eventually makes it.
Again, here the
step is very high.
It tries a few times
and then it gets it.
One thing, this is a
debris, I think, around CMU.
And one thing to note here
is that it doesn't always
get everything in one shot.
It sometimes needs
to try and retry.
And the retry is make more
sense than the previous try.
That is an example of learning
within the context of what
is fed into the model.
In this one change we make--
and I'll get to that-- is--
So in the first
phase of training,
it's the same as before.
With this additional
terrain height information,
we don't add any noise to it.
This is perfect terrain height
that we feed into the model.
And then we encode all of
that, give it to an MLP
and then train this whole system
with reinforcement learning.
It is much faster to train
because you don't need to render
any perception inputs.
The recipe is the
same as before.
We use PPO in simulation.
This time we use IsaacGym.
And the rewards are to
track a target velocity
and then minimize energy.
These are the different
training terrains we use.
And we then get a
single policy that
can walk on all of
these different terrains
in simulation.
The problem is same as before.
How do we get these
dots in the real world?
And most approaches
try to construct a map
and feed that as input.
But instead, what we try to do
is directly integrate depth.
So we render depth
in simulation.
And then we directly
try to supervise that
with the depth encoder that
was trained in the first phase,
using the same approach as
dagger, where we roll out
the student policy and then we
supervise it with the teacher.
And same for the
extrinsic vector.
So here, if you try training
the second phase directly,
it would be an
order of magnitude
slower because rendering
depth takes a lot of time.
So you need to--
this gives you a significant
speedup over how to train it
and lets you deploy
it in the real world
as well, very robustly from
what I just showed you.
So this is the final
deployment policy.
It takes the egocentric
depth from the camera
that's on the robot and the
full proprioceptive history.
And the one change that we've
made here is the use of RNNs.
So we use RNNs so they can give
you a slightly longer context.
So RNNs are Recurrent
Neural Networks
which integrate
information over time.
But they're not known to
preserve very long horizon
information, which is
why most of the community
moved to transformers when they
wanted to do very long sequence
modeling.
We used RNN, which gives a good
enough context to the model,
but it's-- we did not ablate
using a transformer instead
for this task to see if that
improves performance or not.
So now when we
deploy this policy--
to point this out again, I think
stairs are designed for humans.
And this robot is
extremely short.
So relative to the height of the
robot, these stairs are tall.
So there isn't enough
clearance under the robot
to just raise its leg
and then take the step.
Also, when it is
going down, if it just
does it in a way which
everyone else would,
the amount of tilt you
would see in a spot robot
would be much smaller,
because it's a much taller
robot while going down,
whereas for a small robot,
it needs to use
majority of its leg.
And the discrepancy
will be much higher
just because the
legs are smaller.
So what it learns is it learns
to move the leg out sideways
to climb all these stairs.
And this is possible
because we don't
use any predefined gait or
foot motions or any of that.
And we let it be learned
using reinforcement
learning through search.
And this footstep
planning is also emergent.
So it only takes a
step when it needs to.
It doesn't constantly
move its feet
to if we had a predefined
gait of any sort.
And we see that it's
actually quite smooth
and seems to walk with
intention and precision,
and it can handle these kinds
of scenarios very easily.
And then, again,
a same policy can
control for all of these
different variations
of environments.
We don't use any explicit
maps, no explicit gaits.
And that is critical to get the
results we do in this scenario.
We also gave a live
demo at multiple places,
and it was quite robust in
a lot of these scenarios.
And some of these demos,
I think at the bottom one,
the right foot padding just
got out and started limping,
but it continued to
do the full demo.
So let's quickly compare
this with baseline.
I have three key baselines.
The first is just
having a blind policy,
so the same as
what we had before.
The second one uses
a map and then feeds
a slightly noisy version of
the map to see how it works.
It's also trained
with that noise.
And then the last is
what I just demonstrated
directly going from depth.
So we see that the
gap is not that much
for simple terrains
like a slope,
but the moment we get to more
challenging terrains, a map
based method is almost
as bad as blind,
because if we sample from
the same distribution
that other works have done, we
see that the same performance
goes down significantly.
So you need the
final action head
to know whatever it needs
to from perception directly
without adding any
noise or any bottlenecks
for it to work well
in this scenario.
Similarly, for stairs
and discrete obstacles,
we see that the performance
is better than the other two
methods.
But the other methods still
fall behind the performance
of this method.
One interesting
thing is, for stairs,
it's better to be blind and just
learn to put your steps blindly
than to use a map which is
noisy and which gives you
an inaccurate
estimate of where you
might have to place your foot.
Up until now, I've
developed it for locomotion.
And then the same thing
is applicable also
to one scenario in
dexterous manipulation.
So this is the task of just
rotating objects in hand.
It's the same policy, and
it's capable of handling
all of these different
variations of objects.
There's a paper towel
and then there's
a badminton shuttle and all
of these things in this.
And it is capable
of generalizing
to objects with very
different physical properties.
So the weight
variation can be huge,
from 5 grams to
almost 200 grams.
The size-- the coefficient of
friction-- so this is an ice
ball, and on the
right is a kiwi, which
has a slightly rough surface.
The center of mass
on the right is
below the finger because of
the weight that hangs from it,
and on the left it's
slightly above the finger.
And it seems to do fine.
And here the shape is
also very different.
It could be a cube or a cup.
And it performs fine still.
And this was also trained
in simulation, deployed
in the real world 0 shot.
And the key idea
is the same here.
We use proprioceptive history
to give the model as an input,
and then it uses
that to figure out
how to learn a general model.
One hypothesis, since we don't
know exactly what the model is
doing, is it uses proprioceptive
history for contact detection.
So if you look at this--
and if you look at
the bottom joint,
that's what we have plotted.
So we have the
actions, and then we
have the joint position,
which is actually achieved.
And if you look at the time when
it makes the contact or not,
it turns out that the
time when it is not
in contact correlates with
the bottom part of the graph,
where they do overlap
with each other.
And the time when
it does make contact
is at the top of the graph,
where it's in contact,
and then it's not able
to achieve the desired
joint position that
it is commanding.
And this is enough signal for
the network to estimate it.
And if you can
estimate contacts,
you can figure out the shape
and size of the object.
That helps you in
adapting to all
of these different variations.
We did the same, gave live
demos for these as well.
So in the center one,
this is an orange peel.
So if you apply a slightly
larger force than necessary,
it will completely deform.
And on the right is an adapter.
This has not been seen in
training data and simulation.
We don't simulate objects to
this level of granularity.
And again, the same thing can be
applied to drone flight as well.
So we have the same policy,
controlling the drone
at the top and the bottom,
so the same weights, which
tries to estimate the mass and
arm length, and all of these,
of the drones.
The top drone is
four times heavier
than the one at the
bottom, and the arm length
is also three times.
And the same weight is able to
estimate what morphology it's
operating in, and it's able
to adapt and fly the drones.
It's directly controlling
the motor velocity
of each of the propellers.
So it's not abstracting
away to a level
where this becomes
an easy problem.
And it's also very robust.
So this is another drone
with a higher mass.
Initially, it
wobbles a bit I think
it's still trying to estimate
what drone it is flying.
And then we'll
take a tennis ball
and shoot it at the
[? fence. ?] So these are
the propellers of the drone.
And then we'll shoot it
at one of the propellers.
And it's still
quite robust to it.
So I have shown all
of these results.
And then the next
natural question
is, what is there left to solve?
Well, I think almost everything.
We still don't have a
general purpose robot
model that can control a general
purpose hardware to achieve
the task that humans can.
So I'll focus on humanoids as
the general form factor, which
we know can achieve every
single thing that humans can,
and show you the progress that
we have made at Tesla on this.
So you might have seen
some of these videos.
On the left is a biped
walking on a hill.
I've showed similar
results with a quadruped,
but a biped is much less
forgiving because it's
a much more unstable system.
And you need to
be more reactive.
All of these results are
also trained in simulation,
deployed 0 shot on hardware.
And then a more recent
video of the bot dancing,
all real-time on
board autonomous.
Getting the first thing to work
and the 10th thing to work does
not take very long because
the pipeline is very simple.
Once you get one thing to
work, you can actually pump out
a lot more results very easily.
And then this is the progress
we've made on manipulation.
So this is the
same neural network
that takes language as input
and then can execute whatever
the language command is.
Here the key ingredient
is the use of videos.
We learned this from videos
and a little bit of robot data.
And we're able to get this.
This is the progress
that we have
up until now in manipulation.
Again, this is the
same policy, doing
all of these things
conditioned on language.
And we can get decent
performance on these tasks,
but they're not very reliable.
This was learned using
egocentric videos
of humans doing things.
And then we translated that
somehow to the robot results
that I've shown you.
So these results are
not very reliable.
And where we eventually
want to get to
is reliability and dexterity to
the level of what humans have.
This is the eventual goal
where we want to get to.
So we want consistency,
dexterity, agility,
and reliability in the
final system that we have.
So if we take a step
back in all the results
that I presented
for locomotion--
the results that we got were
very agile, dexterous, and very
reliable in the real world.
And those results,
like I mentioned,
were three to four years ago.
So why do we not
already have some
or most of these results for
manipulation in the real world
to the same level of
dexterity and reliability?
And if you go back to the two
things which got locomotion
to work well, one was-- the
simulation technology was ready.
Rigid body contact
was good enough
to get very robust locomotion.
But when it comes
to manipulation,
and if you have to
chop vegetables,
we need to simulate that.
We need to simulate
that, and then we
need to simulate deformable
objects, dough and everything
in simulation to get the
sim-to-real transfer to work
for this.
And then the second
comparison are
rewards, which are much easier
to specify for locomotion.
So if you
programmatically write out
a reward which asks you to
track a certain velocity,
it's complete.
This is the full
task specification.
And now you can just
randomize the terrain,
and then you can get a
general policy out of it.
But that's not true
for manipulation.
So for manipulation, if
you see, depending on--
if you want to chop
a vegetable, and even
if you had this simulated
and full state of simulation,
you would still need to
come up with a reward
which measures the size
of each of the slices
that are cut, and so on, and
that itself will depend on
what exactly is it that you're
trying to cook eventually.
So that's one reward.
And let's say you
put in the work
to do that reward, that
only gets you one task.
It doesn't get you the full
generality of manipulation.
So for example, if you
want to stretch the dough
or put flour on
the dough, you need
to come up with another reward.
So it's a very manual process.
And even if you get
one of this right,
it will not scale
to anything else.
So everything I'll present
from now on is speculative.
So let's start talking
about simulation.
For some scenarios,
like deformable objects,
it is true that we
can simulate it,
except that we cannot
simulate it very fast.
And then there are some other
more complex interactions that
we cannot simulate at all.
But there's no obvious
fundamental reason why we cannot
simulate more complex scenarios
as we get more compute.
So if we bet on
compute, then the hope
is as compute
progresses, simulation
can progress and can give you
progressively better results
in the real world as we expand
the scope of what simulation
can do.
And if we are to learn
from the bitter lesson,
then compute would
be the right bet
to take here, which is you
just hope that simulation
can improve over time.
For those of you not familiar
with the bitter lesson,
it's a very short
piece by Rich Sutton.
I highly recommend
everyone to read it.
I just have the
first line from it,
which says that general methods
that leverage compute are
ultimately the most effective
and by a large margin.
Switching to the other topic
of having a very general reward
model--
the most obvious thing
that comes to mind
is, can we train a
general, large, big model
for general understanding
of the world
and somehow use that to
define the rewards that we
want to improve our policies?
This could work,
but RL, as we know,
has exploited weaknesses
in the model if they exist.
So when we do RLHF, if we
continue tuning with RLHF,
we see that the model goes
completely out of distribution
from what you would
like it to do.
Same with the DeepSeek paper.
They find that if you don't
use verifiable rewards
or rule-based rewards like
they do, at some point
RL can start
exploiting the rewards
that you have defined for them.
So I was optimistic
about simulation.
Why am I optimistic
about this general reward
model, which also seems to be
a very hard problem to solve?
The reason I'm optimistic is
because the absolute worst
case is we get humans to
label all the rewards for us,
and humans are very
scalable because we
have billions of them.
And then before I
end this talk, I
would like to just
revisit how we
approach the idea of robotics.
So most of the
definition that I've
used during the course of the
talk, and most work in robot
learning, tries to
approach robotics
as achieving parity with human.
The day we achieve
that, it will be
a civilization-changing event.
However, that will just be the
first step in everything that we
can achieve from robotics,
because the actuators that we
make driven by electrical torque
and the computers which are
based on silicon as opposed
to carbon than what we have,
it is possible that they can
exploit all of that to achieve
capabilities which humans have
not thought of or cannot figure
out how to do.
So they could do
things much faster,
more efficiently, or better, or
can be much more agile in extras
than what humans are.
And then one system that
we know which has already
done it is AlphaGo, where the
key was to use a sparse reward,
and then lots and lots of
search or reinforcement
learning to get it to discover
new behaviors which are
beyond what humans could think.
So this is, I think, a more
general or a follow-up question.
Can we get robots to not
just match human capability,
but exceed what humans can do?